[Music]
[Applause]
believe nation we leave tomorrow for our
tour 90 days 23 cities we're hopping in
the car tomorrow maybe coming to a city
near you if not you guys can still come
to a tour near us and this is it it's
happening yeah okay yeah there's some
work this week this summer okay okay
alright whatever updates what are you
get it with sign a couple of venues okay
yeah and the poster defender for your
tour okay yeah cuz that needs to get
done oh my good men's stuff yeah I've
been practicing the the the actual
content I did it twice the first three
times I did it I cried myself going
through it something like I'm super
pumped for the intention is gonna come
with is actually a live audience by the
time this comes out I'll have already
done my trial run in Toronto with with a
lion group and then boom Pittsburgh he
would come let's make it happen change
the lives I'm super excited okay I want
to get to three things that you are most
excited for about the tour now you think
about it three things and I'm gonna come
up with three things as well that you're
most excited with the tour if I quickly
like how this all came together as a
recap this started in in July of 2018
when it said it does going to take my
wife to every city in North America with
a million plus people I mean the bold
commitment and something we've been
doing in the workshops they're gonna
have you guys make bold commitments that
was my bold commitment and I didn't know
how I was going to happen Nina had a
full-time job I didn't know how many
cities in North America there even world
with a million plus people there was a
lot of things that were unknown and what
most people do was then you get scared
and you say well I'm not gonna be able
to do that thing because there's too
many unknowns that I know the next step
is doesn't matter you make the bold
commitment then it's immediate momentum
immediate action and so it was like July
1st or 2nd and the July 4th weekend was
coming up and I said west of what's the
closest city to us that we hadn't both
been to it was Boston so I said we go to
Boston this weekend I don't know how
many cities there are that we need to
get to I don't know how we're gonna make
it happen to see all those cities
you know in our lifetime but we're gonna
get started and Boston is happening this
weekend and so I decided I'm told you
know hey Nina
I've decided two things one I'm gonna
take you to every city in North America
with the million plus people and this
weekend we're gonna go to Boston and she
said okay great
and then I messaged Ann Ibrahim where my
film guys and I said hey guys it's like
a Wednesday afternoon or something this
weekend you want to go to Boston I'm
taking Mina you want to come film it and
they said okay and then we went to
Boston there wasn't a solid plan in
place yet we started researching
immediately I started figuring of what
we could do in Boston I message
everybody in my community who's from
Boston we ended up having one day of
helping entrepreneurs it is coffee shop
Meetup
my friend said you have to console this
guy named kiss pain he wants a group
called Boston speaks you should go to a
speaking engagement there great thought
the intro boom had a speaking gig at
Boston speaks we spent the next day
exploring and then the next day we came
back we realized man it all came
together like smoke in the bed together
really quickly even though we didn't
have figured out and I think this is the
big thing that holds some when people
buy you want to have it all figured out
from the start and you'll never get
there but you you will never figure this
whole thing out sitting on the couch
trying to plan your way through it
planet is important but 595 rule five
percent of time planning ninety-five
percent of the time doing in what I
really want to help guide you guys
through as a workshop but there's some
Pittsburgher and the other ones is we're
gonna come up with three both
commitments are you gonna make to
yourself and then we're gonna actually
create an action plan to go off and do
it and then we're gonna break through
your your fears and insecurities to take
immediate momentum at the workshop we're
going to take an immediate momentum then
I'm gonna have you do some comfort zone
stretching exercises so that you can
learn to inoculate yourself against
judgments you stopped caring what people
think of you you stop living your life
baseless of beta temperature based off
of other people's opinions of you it's
late we've been going all day
it is late it's another huge reason why
people don't waste like you're living
your life because you're afraid of what
other people are gonna think of you or
you trying
live up to somebody else's expectations
and that is a losing life and at some
point you have to determine that I'm
gonna live my version of my life this is
what it looks like I'm not here to try
to piss off anybody you're getting
anybody's face but I need to go off and
live my version of my life and I'm gonna
help you make that decision boldly
and powerfully at the workshop and then
the last step is we're gonna schedule
for success I'm gonna look at okay you
have these goals great you've got these
both mittens you made for yourself how
are we gonna make it happen because
you've probably set both commitment to
yourself in the past and you let
yourself down
and then to stop and I'm gonna show you
how to schedule for success so that you
start building immediate momentum in the
workshop together so you're not just
coming to listen to me speak and get
motivated which you'll get but you're
gonna be taking immediate action on your
goals together with me aim we're gonna
create a 24 hour plan a seven-day plan
and then an ongoing plan so that you can
stay committed you can stay bold you can
stay motivated inspired and actually
achieve those goals convinced of you not
just having me there with you and you
get raw rod up for three hours and then
you go home everything else is the same
like that's not an acceptable outcome
for me so I'm pumped I'm pumped for the
tour there's gonna be some amazing
exercise and activities I'm pumped to
meet you and then answer your questions
one-on-one and help get you where you
need to go but this night has to matter
this night has to be your next turning
point I'm putting a ton of pressure on
myself to make that happen for you and
I'm super pumped to meet everybody who's
coming up to the event all right Nina
buy you some time
that was a good little rant there's
listening to you I gotta buy you some
good time there Maggie I gave the
warning you know think you you don't
think of it right now but now you have
to think about it right now the three
things you are most looking forward to
on the tour I think the three things
that I most looking forward to is to see
you in action
Jenna crying she's gonna cry yeah you
said that all the time but I don't know
to what you're just talked about it kind
of site mm-hmm I'm scared
no why are you scared because I have to
do a trial run on Wednesday yeah you
have to do it yeah but that already
happened with yeah yeah so we go through
this I'm making her go through as event
as a workshop attendee and that's one
to saying I really like whatever people
think about me like it that bothers me
I'm always curable they what other
people think about me so safe that's a
scale yeah that's I second well that's
nice but when I see you in your I see me
in action
yeah you are crying anything I wanna cry
it's almost I don't I don't look forward
to cry no no but nothing I'm sorry this
is gonna be good cry this is gonna be
like seeing people make life-changing
moves and being so moved emotion that
you're gonna cry okay that's what's
gonna I mean I get a crisis I need to
bring a couple of tissue box I tried not
to cry because my skin is sensitive and
the second thing I think I think is to
see the cities because those cities now
we have who are going to I will leave
into two together LA and San Francisco
the rest
I've never been to see the city yep
enough on it just eat on the local food
yeah yeah that's good for me I'm most
excited just for the adventure I'm
mostly but I'm most excited for the
adventure with my wife like this is a
crazy thing of spending a quarter of our
year outside of home and not not coming
back until we're finished it and I like
testing stuff I like trying stuff and
this this might be something I'm doing
every year or we never do it again but
you can't think your way through it I
think we work super well together on
projects and this kind of stuff but I'm
excited to see just how it how it goes
and how we grow through the the 90 days
so I'm super pumped to helping
entrepreneurs I mean I'm us I love it
this is the thing I'm more concerned
about I need to make sure I don't die
[Music]
and I'm gonna fight you hard on it you
so hard you're gonna be my wife yes you
no no no no I don't need fuel
I don't need fuel I need restraint but
did you know when you're angry
it's scary scary you guys have never
seen him
yeah really when you have focus to do
something I'm afraid you know well you
fight you see just you're gonna need to
fight here's it thank you clown here's
that I'm most worried about beside the
only like big thing I'd be worried about
for the whole tour is if if this started
negatively impacting our relationship
then I then we'd have to cancel the tour
because that's not an acceptable outcome
for me I don't see that happening but
that would be the only that'd be the
only like thing that would kill the tour
the thing besides that that I would be
fearful of is I invest so much into
making sure that it's fantastic I'll
pour so much of myself to make sure that
I'm bringing value and helping people
because I know that I can but then I I
will I will I'll get sick like I'll push
myself so much I won't even notice it
that I'll get sick and then won't sleep
and won't eat and like figure through
the bathroom and all that stuff so I
can't get sick right because it's 90
days so you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to like lock me up and we
need weights you have some kind of plan
you know we need to have a plan I can
see that I can see the night's going
crazy long right yeah even though it
like there's a scheduled event I need to
make sure that I still get home and
sleep good thing is the hotel that you
should tell they just out they will kick
you out okay yeah I'm legit worried
about me just with working on stuff it's
easy like I know I need my videos down
and that kind of stuff is okay but when
it involves helping out on I here's the
thing
I can't let an entrepreneur go when I
know that I can help them and they
haven't gotten the message yet sometimes
when I'm eating people 101 we have a
quick conversation they got the message
and I know they're off they got they can
go to take they can take action
sometimes though I meet people and they
ask the question and and then that leads
to five deeper questions and and they're
fighting me on it and I and I haven't
broken through yet and I know that
there's something there and I know that
I've got something but they're not Liz
maybe they haven't picked it up yet I
can't let them go like if I let that if
I let an entrepreneur go that I know I
can help that I didn't help and they've
now gone home feeling like they didn't
get the message that destroys me like I
wouldn't be able to sleep at all and so
I have to stay with that person until
they get it and so that's gonna be the
fight like you're gonna come in his head
when we gotta go like I can't
I would like physically need to be drag
dead or something I don't know I don't
know I don't know how we're gonna deal
with it I don't know I'm so separate on
that like I'll sacrifice everything to
make sure that that person gets the help
I'll sacrifice my own health to make
sure that that happens because it's even
selfish for me because knowing that
billion that they got it will then allow
me I'll sit well that night knowing that
I helped but knowing that they left and
I didn't get the message through them
will destroy me now that times 23 right
I don't know I don't know how I don't
know we have to manage that somehow okay
yeah okay we have to think about okay so
so help your affairs isn't over to
number three I would say I would say
seeing the cities and just being with
you and enjoying like I think just
enjoying a different flavor to my
schedule
I'm very regimented on my schedule I
lead it unstructured there's not very
much wasted time at all on any day and
I'm giving most of it up like I had very
little control I have I have top-level
control of what I'm doing in general but
what am i meeting people I have no idea
what am i recording videos I have no
idea what am i working at I have no idea
it's Nina planning with my assistant
Sandra together they're controlling my
life right for 90 days which is I like
knowing that Tuesday is my YouTube
filming day and now I need to film on on
a Thursday afternoon and then I have to
do a meeting here and it's a total
different change for me I think I'll
crush it to be honest like I'm pretty
pumped by it
I like the idea being I
I'm a great follower when when there's a
good system and is a good leader when
the system sucks or is a bad teacher
leader I'm the worst follower of all
time something of some dance classes
I've taken when when the teacher is
really slow we're boring
I'll always yeah after you I'll do my
own thing and be the worst student of
all time because I got it I feel like I
got it and now I'm bored so create but
if I'm with somebody who's good who's
pushing me and teaching me I'll I'll
consume everything and like yes tell me
exactly what I want to do so I'm not a
bad student I'm just I'm bad when it's a
bad system I'm pumped to be a follower
under a system that I built with with
Nina and Sandra figuring everything out
so I'm excited to see how that goes I've
just mean 90 days of just being a
follower to what you guys are creating
for me yeah we get to Q&A each time when
these videos if you have a question for
me or Nina a Nina or Nina either way
leave it in the comments below and we'll
answer it next week let's get to some of
the questions from last week so we got
here the trend that George loved it what
a great opportunity much love ever Anna
Nina thank you for the Levitt render
hopefully we will see you on the tour
and you get to meet Nina on the tour -
Nina's gonna be there at each event just
coming to watch me in action and tear up
but also you guys get to do selfies with
Nina obviously what come on they care
about if you if you care about Nina
give us a love and then people want
something with Nina - my flippered
starts you got your hang pretty good huh
huh sounds like some great prizes
awesome I got my Oh cuz last time I set
the video by doing the clapping and I
hit some weird nerve it was fine so yes
thank you for the love Clifford
appreciate it man and yes the prices are
pretty nuts we give them over a hundred
thousand dollars of prizes away lots of
mentorship lots of coaching lots of just
lots of great prizes so pump to do that
I talked to meet people but also give
the prizes away and see the added that
people get from that next Suzy I'm so
exciting
both of you you're gonna kill it I love
it I'm coming from Williamsburg Virginia
seven hours lol I love that that is
hustle probably coming to Pittsburgh if
you're coming from Virginia the closest
I just made arrangements for a dog
sitter to come to my house while I'm at
your event only three days from me
though I'm sure you'll miss your dog but
the dog would be safe and so happy to
see when you get home dogs are pretty
darn resilient yes that's probably the
biggest thing that Nina's your family I
guess in the dogs yeah so my sister is
gonna come she has a dog as well and
she's gonna come and stay at our place
for the three months and be with the
dogs and take them out and the dogs have
a third friend now to be able to hang
hang out with and hopefully we'll get
updates and stuff and how they're doing
Nina always misses the dogs tremendously
when we go and she sees other dogs on
the street and always thinking about our
dogs but three months is gonna be a
crazy long time yeah so I I appreciate
you coming and leaving your dogs alone
for three days three days to three hours
three days you sent her three days
super-pumped look forward to meeting you
I love you so much I love the people so
much who come from out of town it means
so much to me that means so much to me
to the people who are put in their
community put your goals ahead of your
convenience like Suzy's gonna win
Susan's gonna win for peope someone's
gonna come seven hours out of town to
like this is important right it won't be
convenient for you to hit your goals and
the people who say no I'm gonna make
this happen
those are the people who win those are
the people who win when you finally put
your goals ahead of your convenience is
when you actually start to win so I'm
still pumped Suzy I'm so pumped to meet
you
can't wait I'm gonna see you in two days
Kristina even though you don't have any
southern and very few East Coast dates I
will try to make it to one of your
events let's do it Kristina bring it
take your cue take your cue from Suzy
goals ahead of your convenience let's go
I wanna meet you I I think the people
who come from out of town will even get
more value because you're like you've
committed like this has to matter that's
how much I'm Taylor this has to
I'm destroyed if you come and you didn't
get value from the event right like 10
times at least the value from the event
I'm destroyed and so four people come
from out of town this has to matter and
those are the people were hungry ready
for change so I'm pumped do it Phil hey
there Evan love the upbeat Vince thanks
for sharing the results of your hard
work hope the hand is better ouch thank
you for the love Phil yes I've never had
that happen I'm sure for whoever is out
there as a doctor will know like
whatever nerve or acupressure point that
I hit as much of when I had a guy come
over to occupy me and he hit some some
part up here I put my laundry remember
when dr. Evan his name was Evan - came
over like it's some thing here and then
like I got nauseous I had them I was
falling just a little tiny prick here I
was on the floor that was also because
he did some you know was this one known
was this one not so easy to get out it
was better but like yes I hit some crazy
nerve here in my hand and anyway I'll
try not to do that again gotta fix how I
clap the hell in Chihuahua it's always
great to see you two together
but timo being in the video makes it
awesome thank you for your belief nation
tribe I appreciate that and yes you know
when when I get to meet people and put a
face behind the you're watching it from
your computer for your phone you know
and and now we get to see each other
face to face and you watch me I come
into your your living room or your
office or for some people in your
bathroom some people in your shower
spill in the car you know now we get to
meet face to face and I love that and I
think we've actually built something
pretty amazing here with the leaf nation
I think we have one of the most positive
communities anywhere online and I'm just
I'm just super pumped to meet you
but t-mobile you know videos makes it
better so Timo has passed out hardcore
we've had a long day and it's late at
night right now we wait for him to go to
bed and then we did a Nike Live and
whole bunch of other stuff so we're
reporting this video past our bedtime
even now but teemo's passed out so we're
not gonna wake him up depending on here
mx4 diem
no Emma or xd4 horn bo0 says it what
does that mean max max the boys max the
max upon master or buzz Max or boys yeah
what the a Oh max for boy okay that's
decent max D for boys anyway it's what
I'm analyzing that mess that voice nurse
Master boys Master Mazda boys Mazda boys
nice good job Nina good Giardina love
you haven't please keep a positive vibe
up thank you for your love and that
enough opportunity to dive deeper and
create more positive vibe and and you
know I love the encouragement keep the
positive vibe up I don't I don't have
another gear you know I I'm I'm positive
you know most of the time like 90% of
the time so even if it wasn't I think
even it hurts you know I think a lot of
times actually is negative for my
business I think if I make content that
was negative I would get more views
people would rather escape and lean into
negativity and complained and they would
try to get better and improve that's
just not how I want to roll you know I
want to create content I'm proud of and
that that creates a positive difference
so I'll promise I'll keep up the
positive vibe I have no other gear even
even if only eight people were watching
I'll still do it also be positive can't
help it anyway just finally got a big
smile on your face you just like it
you like the positive I King Raphael
let's go Vegas with like 20 exclamation
points I love it King Raphael we will
see you in Vegas our first time we
haven't actually didn't because -
because we're going to the Grand Canyon
right yeah continue you know it's a long
drive
I've never been to Vegas for whatever
reason I've been a bunch of places but
I've never had a speaking gig or
anything in Vegas so good we're gonna go
we're gonna go we're gonna see King
Raphael we're gonna see the Grand Canyon
and we're gonna see who which one is
more impressive King
or the Grand Canyon I'm excited right
you could take a poll who was more
impressive but I'm super I'm super
excited for Vegas hustler babe are you
coming to OKC
Oklahoma City no we're not going to
Oklahoma City but we're coming to Tulsa
Oklahoma come to Tulsa Tulsa I don't
know what the distance is but it's
pretty close pretty fish pretty close so
come on out we will see you in Tulsa Oh
Who am as de I saw you when New Jersey's
another medicine the main thing I like
that new jersey awesome look at the Tony
Robbins event maybe I hope we came and
said hi and for anybody like come and
say hi have you ever seen me I love I
love meeting fans is one of the greatest
things of all time for me just come and
say hi take a picture I got stopped in
the in our condo building yesterday by
someone who like oh man I'm a fan of
your videos it's like okay awesome I got
something wholefoods by a cashier the
day before it's like oh yeah you work in
karma go watch a Chan all the time like
that cuz of it like it never grows old
for me I love that stuff so I always
always talk and say hi and I'm looking
forward to meeting you all in a future
city on the tour to lose good luck on
your tour of an antenna Thank You DC
believer I live in Florida awesome
the last part your name is believers so
what are you gonna do come out yes goals
ahead of the convenience come make it
happen look forward to seeing you there
guys gonna wrap the video here we look
forward to seeing one of the tour spots
we are starting off kicking off
Pittsburgh so the next update video for
you will be I already haven't done
Pittsburgh it's very close this weekend
Columbus before the next it's happening
like we're on the moment where it's all
of this time thinking and planning and
you know getting ready and it's like
it's happening and honestly one of the
things is I know it's long I know a
sunny days but I'm also I wanted to I
wanna enjoy as we go and not sometimes
you get so ready and so amped at least
think about vacations or like some big
moment or like a salsa performance so
you spent so much time preparing and
getting ready and then it happens and
then it's over
yeah and it's done and then we get 90
days forget to really enjoy it but like
a
I want to really enjoy each city along
the way it's been build up it's a big
moment for everybody hopefully coming
out and I don't want us to enjoy it and
we need to find us time last time we
kicked me out of the house every now and
then okay
big night tonight I'm saying we got Amy
with us we're living with Danny too you
know just saying I'm just saying that's
all I'm just saying you're in charge of
planning so you got planned us time in
there as well I'm just following the
system guys thank you so much all the
love looking forward to see onions tour
where do we send people to Oh to the
tour right so click the link if you want
to go buy your tickets click the link
and go buy your tickets we'll see you
there
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon